SCP-096 Vs SCP-3008.
096 may be able to tear almost anything apart,
but does it have the mental strength to put
together an Ikea shelving unit without going
insane?
This is the Shy Guy Vs The Infinite Ikea.
This flat pack labyrinth has trapped and claimed
many a soul.
The maze-like inner structure is only made
more hazardous with the inclusion of The Staff,
an army of faceless humanoid creatures eager
to kill anyone left inside after dark.
However, not only does SCP-096 not need food
to survive, it’s unlikely the staff would
do any meaningful damage to it, and it would
probably rather enjoy being trapped in a giant
warehouse with fewer people to see its face.
But if someone looked at a photo of it on
the outside, the psychic link would allow
it to intuitively know which direction to
run in, and escape the Infinite Ikea immediately.